hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the norway chess 2022 it's
vishwanathan anand vs magnus carlson a
match that um you guys don't need to ask
twice for me to show uh and this one you
did ask for more than twice and for good
reasons as usual uh it's a classical
game and it's uh really really a
wonderful one many winning chances uh
you guys will enjoy it there will be two
positive video moments um uh because of
what requires to be solved in this game
is definitely not easy so hope you guys
are ready for it let's check it out
anand has the white pieces and the pawn
is already on e4 uh so magnus replies e5
we have knight to f3 knight to c6 and
the bishop the c4 for anand goes for the
italian game knight to f6 magnus strikes
back with two knights defense and the d3
going for the calm modern bishop's
opening bishop to e7 and the both
players castle so castles castles and
rook to e1 so this is all very standard
stop only top engine moves uh d6 and a4
grabbing more space here on the queen
side knight to a5 magnus goes after the
bishop and bishop back to a2 we have c5
you move the knight so now you can
advance your c pawn you grab more space
in the center we have c3 by anand and
knight back to c6 now uh knight to a3
and now pawn to h6 and here
bishop to d2 is the most played move
here but magnus goes for knight to c2
which is not new it's uh uh just a
little bit rarer uh and now a6 by anand
uh we have knight to e3 and here we have
bishop to e6 challenging the light squad
bishop here this bishop is an incredible
piece so of course we want to counter it
uh and here
anand plays a knight to d5 and this is
now a new move so already as of move 13
we have a completely new game let's see
how magnus continues rook to e8 he just
develops
and knight back to d2 now this knight
could go let's say c4 to b6 but that's
not gonna happen of course the knight is
coming to f1 and later on you can
re-maneuver it to e3 or even g3 if
needed so here b5 magnus strikes in the
center not just allowing wishy to
remaneuver for free knight to f1 and now
comes bishop captures on d5 this is uh
one of those moments where you would
much rather capture with the knight but
you can't because you would just blunder
a piece and i've seen this happen many
many times you know in bars
or libraries where people just wander
pieces so here are bishop captures and
the five bishop captures knight captures
and pawn characters so here anan's
d-pawn is double the but
magnus now has to move the knight from
the active c6 square so knight to a5 and
now comes pawn to b4 by anand always a
good move and especially in this
position and magnus goes back knight to
b7 if you go for trades here let's say c
captures on b4c captures on b4 and
knights to b7 now you could also play a
captur sun b5 so this is one way to go
about it let's say rook captures queen
captures and now queen to f3 it's a very
very uh nice position for anand like i
said the knight can always uh find a
nice square on f5 and if magnus wants to
prevent this he will have to play g6
weakening the king side even further
but okay we have b4 first knight to b7
and now comes rook to e2 by anand again
you could always go for this it's uh
it's always in the position uh but anand
says let's just keep it close let's play
rook to e2 and this is a very very deep
move uh as you'll see so here uh c
captures on b4 c captures and now magnus
plays a5 and he wants to just trade down
everything on the queen side uh a
captures on b5 we have eight captures on
b4 and now rook back to b1 saying that
now anan's rook that is on e2 so
conveniently placed will come to b2 and
then you will start winning things on
the b file and the best thing to counter
this idea is by playing knight to c5 and
now if rook captures on b4 we're gonna
play rook to a1 so you give up upon
temporarily but you gain a lot of
activity uh the queen will also come to
a8 and it's it's not going to be easy
for white to withstand all of this but
magnus played queen to d7 he just uh
threatens to pick up the b5 pawn and
anand says be my guest i i really hope
you do that because if you do that uh i
i win the game if you're not capture on
b5 i'm gonna capture on b4 that's it you
move the queen i win the knight game
over so of course magnus doesn't do that
he plays knight to c5 and now comes um
just grabbing the the pawn rook captures
on b4 and here magnus
does not have an easy time playing this
now the b pawn will start marching
forward and it's already on magnus's
half of the board it's a very unpleasant
position to play for black uh and you
should play rook uh rook to b8 rook e to
b8 and uh uh try try to fight this but
magnus plays queen to f5 and he gives
anand just enough to push for the win if
he plays uh or rather if he finds the
correct idea so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this um
incredible move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not worrying about
the d3 pawn and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
to e3 this is what anand played
and this is now a big trouble for magnus
because it's not clear how to continue
this i'm just going to give you two
continuations that are not as great and
then i'm going to show you what magnus
played uh or rather maybe it's even
better than what magnus played but um it
it's very hard to say so here uh one
idea is to just um uh disregard the d3
pawn and play rook to b8 because this
rook really belongs here we're still
going to capture the knight and after d
captures on c5 plane knight to e3 we're
going to kick away the queen and once
the queen moves now we're going to play
rook to a4 that's the good stuff now we
don't have to worry about this pawn
because we're attacking the a8 rook and
after rook captures queen captures we
get this position we
traded down very nicely uh our pawn is
defended by the knight we can just uh
push the queen push the pawn and we are
going to win this game eventually so
this is not very good for magnus the
other thing to try is queen captures on
d3 yeah and that does seem like a
reasonable move you attack the pawn why
not capture it the problem is after
queen captures the knight captures
attacking the rook we're going to attack
the knight and once the knight goes back
we're still going to capture it
characters captures now again anan gets
two past pawns and after this let's say
b6 we're going to play rook 8 to b8 the
rook is no longer needed on the a file
knight to e3 and it's very very
difficult to play this for black rook uh
will come somewhere let's say rook to d8
now comes b7
and it's just uh very very difficult uh
even some ideas like maybe knight to c4
to a5 to c6 will be very very
problematic for for white not right away
but um at some point because for the
moment the knight is very nicely placed
here guarding this pawn and preventing
the sea pawn from being pushed forward
but this is all
winning winning for for anand so instead
magnus plays the third option and that
is knight captures on d3 uh you could
also just wait and play rook to a3 but
um uh well
it's just too complex of a position so
magnus plays knight captures on d3 and
now we have knight to g3 this is the
move that uh anand has to play if he
wants to win this game and now where
where do you put the queen of course the
queen has to keep an eye on the knight
so the only square is g6 or h7 here we
have queen to h7 if you go queen to g6
then even rook to g4 will further harass
the queen and put the rook on a very
nice attacking g file so just queen to
h7 by magnus and now comes rook 4 to b3
now threatening to win the knight knight
to c5 and now again we trade this bishop
for knight that's why this bishop to e3
was such a crucial idea bishop captures
d captures and now pawn to b6 and uh the
best thing about this position is that
carlson's queen is completely stuck on
h7 uh there's just no good way to
to get that queen into the game uh here
we have rook e to d8 uh putting pressure
on the default or you could play queen
to g6 right away but just b7 is is
incredibly strong we're gonna play the
rook here and rook b6 attack the queen
again uh just not a lot uh not a lot of
squares for that queen discarded by the
night by the night by the queen by the
queen also defended by the queen and by
the rook so it's uh really you can put
it on g6 but it's not going to do
anything there so here rook e to d8 and
now comes pawn to b7 attacking the rook
here rook 8 to b8 and now rook to b6
here you could play a lot of things but
rook to b6 is just beautiful taking away
that last square that the black queen
has and now there really isn't a move
for magnus magnus however always finds a
move even when there is no move to be
found and he plays c4 he starts pushing
his own pass pawn which also frees up
the bishop a little bit and you have to
be a little bit careful of what you play
because uh the next move is crucial and
this is this is the one for the for the
records if anand finds this one
then everything just falls into place
but it is only if he finds it so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this move as this one is even harder to
spot than the previous one uh while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on playing rook to c6
this is what anand played but this is
not the move that wins the game the
actual move that wins the game uh is
queen to g4 so it's similar to anan's
idea on a player rook to c6 he went for
the c4 pawn because the c4 pawn is uh
kind of the only counter play magnus has
here but it is important to play queen
to g4 and go after the pawn this way
because now we're not only threatening
to capture the pawn but also if this
knight comes to f5 then well that's just
not a position that you can hold
let's uh explore some of the options
here if you play rook captures on d5 and
the why wouldn't you it's a free pawn uh
then anand would play h4 first creating
a little
a little bit of reading room for for his
king and you have to be careful if this
rook moves you don't want to blunder the
rook on b1 or something but now knight
to f5 is definitely coming so here uh
magnus will play something like h5 kick
away the queen and now we just pick up
the pawn we could play queen captures
and c4 but we could also play the cooler
queen to c8 check and pick up the pawn
this way of course the rook cannot
capture we just bring another queen into
the game so here uh rook back to d8 and
now queen captures on c4 and now it
seems like okay maybe you don't have all
that much the problem is this knight
this knight on the c6 square and that's
just unstoppable uh to give you an
example let's say queen d3 we can trade
queens let's say captures captures now
comes rook to c6 we are of course
threatening rook to c8 and once this
rook goes back now we start bringing the
knight into the game knight f5 attacks
the bishop and the bishop has to keep an
eye on the rook here uh so it's it's
very hard to find a move if you play
something like bishop to f8 we play rook
to c7 and again no no good move for for
black here for example g6 knight to e3
and after any move by black because
black is really out of any useful moves
knight to c4 and now the knight is
coming to a a5 and c6 and that's of
course gonna be game game winning e4
let's say king f1 rook to e8 preparing
to push the pawn let's say king e2 even
better rookie 7 offering a trade but now
just captures captures and now knight to
e5 we are getting the c6 square it's a
light square so
there is nothing black can do about this
whatever black does knight c6 and that's
it you have to move the rook somewhere
uh it doesn't really matter where rook
to c6 we're gonna promote the pawn to a
queen after capture so we're just gonna
capture it and that's it we're up a full
rook and of course completely winning so
that's what happens if you play
something like rook captures on d5 but
of course you don't have to do that you
could play the much stronger bishop to
c5 just challenge this rook get the
bishop out of this nasty square still
doesn't matter because now we're gonna
play queen captures on c4 we're going to
give up the exchange and look at this
bishop captures rook captures uh the
queen still cannot get into the game all
of these squares uh sorry but that um
are covered and there's just no way to
activate the queen for example h5 we're
gonna play h4 not allow the queen to
kick away the knight and after king h8
because you really don't have a move
here now we're just gonna start bringing
the knight into the game uh let's say
queen f5 now because the um f5 square
has been vacated knight to g5 even and
this is just terrible terrible uh
position for black for example king g8
we're going to play d6 the other pass
pawn is marching forward g6 we're going
to play knight to e4
and after uh king g7 g3 we're going to
play rook to d7 we have to try making
some moves but it's uh just uh little by
little we improved the position for
white let's say queen f3 not allowing
the knights to jump because the queen
would hang we just play rook to b3 kick
away the queen and after queen to the uh
sorry and after queen term uh e2 uh now
we just play knight to c5 and uh there's
just no defending this position rule
goes back to d8 rook the e3 were even
gonna win this pawn and that's it
there's there's no counter play here
queen b2 rook captures an e5 and the two
connect the two pass pawns will just be
too much for for black to handle so it's
a lot of moves uh but uh it just works
the problem is after c4 uh anand did not
play queen to g4 anand played the other
one rook to c6 which i'm sure some of
you found as well as it goes after the
c4 pawn
but now magnus has this move that allows
him to activate the queen and that is
queen to d3 that's also one of the
reasons c4 was played to grab control
over the d3 square and now especially
you can't really move the queen anywhere
since anand moved the rook because the
rook on b1 would hang so what can you do
here anan still has some pressure if he
captures the queen for example king to
f1
and now you have to be very very careful
for example if again if you capture this
pawn it's a game over after knight to f5
the bishop needs to keep an eye on this
square
in order to defend and there's just no
good move to do it if you play bishop
back to f8 then you lose control of this
square and if you try something like
bishop to f6 to keep an eye on this
square then we just pick up the bishop
captures 97 check picks up the rook and
it's game over so what you would have to
do after king f1 is actually play bishop
to f8 only way to continue the game now
rook c7 and uh
uh anand will just have very very uh
annoying pressure here all the time rook
captures on the e5 king e1 we're gonna
play rook c5 offroad rook trade captures
captures we're gonna play king to d2 and
it's an incredibly complicated position
uh but at the end of the day it's a pass
pawn on b7 which is a light square and
you can't do all that much about it with
the dark square bishop and the rook can
never move the the
from the back rank so this was still the
way to kind of put some pressure but
after king to a queen to f1 now it's a
much much easier for carlson to equalize
he puts the bishop on f8 and now all of
the uh secrets that were in the position
uh are no longer there so here rook
captures on c4 grabbing that pawn now
it's possible uh queen captures an f1
with czech king captures and now rook to
d7 putting pressure on the b7 pawn uh
rook the c8 now uh attacking the rook
here and now rook b captures on b7 we
have rook captures on b7 rook captures
and knight to f5 now so still uh some
pressure but it is it is not enough uh
the the material on the board is equal
and not enough to push we have rook to
d7 now comes g4 and here of course you
don't capture the rook if the point if
you capture the pawn knight d7 just wins
the game the bishop is pinned so after
g4 we have pawn to g6 and now knight
captures on h6 as the bishop of course
cannot move but he was also in this
position and move 40 that anand and the
carlson agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here it's just a
draw and that's just it for example if
king h7 we're going to play capture sun
here captures here and that's it it's a
rook end game very very easily uh drawn
for example you're going to play h4 f5
captures captures and captures and now
rook captures on d5 and of course this
is now a draw we could play a few more
moves f4 as the pawn cannot move uh king
g6 attacks the rook rook g5 check king
f6 king to g2 we bring the king into the
game rook d2 check king g3 and now after
captures and captures uh of course this
is now a draw rook f2 check we push the
king back rook a2 we're gonna start
checking the white king and there's no
way to win this of course
uh so after knight captures on h6 the
players agree to a draw and what what an
amazing game between these two uh world
elite players both of them world
champions in classical chess uh
and um it's just uh remarkable so anand
uh spotted after carlson's a
queen to f5 which is essentially a
blunder this incredible bishop to e3
idea uh but in a position where uh yeah
it's hard to find a move but this c for
a very nice resource resourcefulness by
magnus just creating that outpost for
the queen on d3
and uh queen to g for the only way to
push this for a win uh because it just
uh gains control of this of this you
push pressure here you
you can play knight to f5 you put
pressure on c8 so all of this is just in
the position and um well it's basically
the only move that allowed anand to win
the game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it sorry for a bit of a longer
video but the lines uh
required it uh so i hope you enjoyed
that as well uh i would like to thank
varun sudarsanan richard knapp raymond
uh young cedra simmons and david kimura
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event uh until it finishes uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day